well for us I actually was told by very
one of the largest manufacturers in the
world that it would cost thirty dollars
more for the laptop to be
environmentally friendly and I thought
you know that's just too much money
we're not going to do it and they were
wrong we've made the most
environmentally friendly laptop ever
made and it wasn't it was by trying to
do trying to design for the developing
world and for children the batteries
can't explode right I mean take your
company they have recalls about every
six months of millions of batteries that
are exploding using lithium ion
technology and so we explore different
technology and the batteries that would
last much longer on the typical lithium
ion battery lasts some 500 tarde to
recharge cycles which is if you're
running off of battery all the time you
know a year a year and a half two years
well ours last 2000 charge recharge
cycles and so that's like five years
right even when you're running off
battery all the time and lithium Pharaoh
phosphate which which we use as well as
nickel metal hydride lithium Pharaoh
phosphate actually with processing
decomposes into fertilizer now people
are still sort of working this out is
the new new technology but those are the
components of fertilizer so that's
that's pretty great the reason that the
OLPC laptop sort of got the title of the
greenest laptop ever made was was was
multifold it looked but but much of much
of much of the um we rode the e use sort
of legislation for reduction of
hazardous substances so all of the
factories the world were retooling so
they could ship to the EU so the EU
legislation really made a profound
difference for that but in addition we
got rid of the mercury which wasn't
required but we used in LED backlight so
that was really great as far as
hazardous substances but then you're
left with things that that aren't really
met
in the current way people measure
greenness like they say they mandate
Energy Star compliance but but the the
XO laptop is 15 times better than Energy
Star compliance mandates which is you
know you think well they don't sort of
set the bar high enough like people
could do more and and you know I talk to
people and they say well how do you
legislate that everybody can't do it I
mean how do you legislate that that's a
question but but also some of the
requirements for their there's a spac
it's called I Tripoli 1680 2006 and I
Tripoli doesn't really matter what it
stands for the to the ease in it are
electrical engineering and it's the
largest electrical engineering society
in the world and they came up with sort
of a standard for what environmentally
friendly laptops and computers should be
and this organization said okay we're
going to make that into you know a sushi
card and you check you can do each thing
and if you get enough checkmarks you get
this gold award when we got that but it
doesn't even count how long the product
lasts does the laptop last two years or
five years or you know what the what the
footprint is what's the size and weight
of it how much of this would end up in
landfill like those aren't counted even
in this and so I think that there's a
lot more that can be done but the
question is really you know do you
regulate it or how do you incentive
these bars they're probably not hard
enough
you